[Música]
y en directo a vamos a España el partido
de ultraderecha box presentó hoy en el
congreso de los diputados una propuesta
que plantea derogar la ley del aborto en
vigor en el país y reintroducir la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo en
el código penal según los
ultraderechistas el aborto no es un
derecho ampliamos con nuestra
corresponsal en Madrid Marina Colorado
Marina muy buenas noches cuéntenos En
qué consiste esta propuesta del partido
vox y cuáles son sus antecedentes en
España
pues incluye dos ingredientes
principales por un lado pretende derogar
la vigente ley del aborto en España esa
ley protege la práctica hasta la semana
14 de gestación sin supuestos Es decir
de manera libre a partir de esa semana
solo se podrá interrumpir el embarazo si
hay malformaciones o enfermedad grave de
la embarazada o desde la semana 22 solos
y se detecta una anomalía incompatible
con la vida del feto vox con esta
propuesta pretende volver a introducir
el aborto en el código penal tal y como
estaba en 1985 cuando sólo había tres
supuestos en los que se podía abortar
violación riesgo grave de la Salud
Mental o física de la mujer o
malformación del feto y por otro lado
abogan por sustituirla por y texto
textualmente cito textualmente políticas
públicas que protejan a la mujer
embarazada y al concebido no nacido y
ahí es donde entra en juego lo que ya
intentaron Aunque sin éxito intro en
Castilla y león una región en la que vox
gobierna con el PP que es el partido de
derecha en enero anunció que se
ofrecerían a las mujeres escuchar el
latido del feto durante el primer
trimestre además de ecografías 4d antes
de poder abortar esto lo quieren ampliar
al territorio nacional pero al ser un
proyecto no de ley no tiene carácter
vinculante y no tiene casi ninguna
posibilidad de salir adelante Pero lo
que sí hace es forzar el debate
parlamentario sobre el tema para que
cada partido exponga su posición al
respecto
Marina el momento en el que han hecho
esta propuesta en la cámara baja es
significativo por qué
Pues porque se da dos días antes de que
el congreso de los diputados vote
definitivamente Y seguramente apruebe la
reforma a la ley del aborto que impulsó
el gobierno de Pedro Sánchez en 2022 una
reforma que quita algunos de los
obstáculos existentes al aborto como los
tres días de reflexión o la entrega de
información con opciones a la embarazada
además permite que las jóvenes de 16 y
17 años puedan interrumpir de manera
voluntaria su embarazo sin permiso
parental también esta propuesta de vox
llega cinco días después de que el
tribunal constitucional avalará la ley
de plazos sobre el aborto en vigorde
desde 2010 una sentencia que tardó 13
años en dar respuesta a un recurso
presentado por el derechista partido
popular PP que entonces cuestionaba su
constitucionalidad ahora los de este
partido recibieron esta decisión como
válida el cambio de postura del PP es
para vox ahora una oportunidad de
ganarse los votos de los ciudadanos más
conservadores en un 2023 de elecciones
tanto regionales en el mes de mayo como
generales a finales de este año